señor rosanía bienvenido y un gusto
tenerlo acá explíquenos un poco qué
significa este reconocimiento para
desmitificar la idea de que solo hay
justicia cuando hay cárcel es muy
importante y porque tienes dos variables
lo primero el presidente de la jec dijo
que aquí había una sistematicidad por
parte de la institución de la fuerza
pública en colombia o sea esto no es un
tema aleatorio ni de manzanas podridas
como se intentó decir en el momento sino
que sí fue una política institucional y
eso es lo más importante en estos
reconocimientos y lo segundo esto lo que
hace es que le da un impulso a la
jurisdicción especial para la paz donde
el reconocimiento y la verdad puede ser
digamos negociada en términos de
justicia de cárcel y las víctimas no
querían que el caso de los pasos de los
'falsos positivos' llegara a lage porque
decían que esto no pertenecía al
conflicto sino que era un crimen de
estado como este reconocimiento ayuda a
ese pulso ayuda mucho porque lo que
marca aquí es que la justicia especial
para la paz es el organismo idóneo para
hablar de los crímenes de guerra que se
vivió en colombia no se puede dejar en
una justicia ordinaria tiene que ser una
justicia especial y sobre todo porque
esto lo que busca es reconocer la verdad
los victimarios que los victimarios
cuente realmente qué fue lo que pasó más
allá del tema de las penas que era lo
que en un principio las víctimas querían
era mayor cárcel pero aquí lo que
estamos negociando es menos cárcel por
mayor verdad y en ese balance de menos
cárcel por mayor verdad un brillo a un
brigadier general reconoció
responsabilidades en los 'falsos
positivos' que implica esto para ese
caso y en general para el ambiente de
justicia en colombia refuerza la
hipótesis del presidente de la
jurisdicción especial para palpar a la
paz donde dice que esto fue una política
institucional siempre se dijo que eran
rangos menores de sargentos soldados o
máximo tenientes capitanes pero que un
general reconozca su participación ya lo
que demuestra es que las órdenes venían
directamente desde los altos mandos
militares y cuando se creó la justicia
transicional este esquema de la gente
una de las mayores críticas sobre todo
por parte de sectores de derecha era que
este organismo iba a traer impunidad
este reconocimiento ayuda o no frente a
esa imagen y hacia las críticas ante la
gente no lo que demuestra es que aquí sí
se está conociendo la verdad de fondo
por eso les digamos muchos actores en
colombiano están interesados en que esto
avanzara ejemplo los empresarios no
llegaron que fueron financiadores del
conflicto y muchos otros actores la han
atacado porque porque no quieren que se
conozca este tipo de verdad y este tipo
de reconocimientos aquí solo en este
reconocimiento tenemos casi 250 civiles
muertos reconocidos por las fuerzas
militares y que más se ha sabido de esta
justicia transicional ahora lo
importante y estos datos son reveladores
en la dictadura de pinochet tuvimos 3000
muertos en la justicia especial para la
paz un dato ya una cifra que pudo dar
fue de 6 mil 400 muertos quiere decir
que el doble de inocentes fue han sido
asesinados en el conflicto colombiano es
diferente a la dictadura de pinochet